usually the richer someone gets the more
conservative they are with their
investments this makes sense as the
focus generally shifts from wealth
growth to wealth preservation with
growing riches even some of the richest
people in the world who took massive
risks to get what they are today have
grown more conservative with time bill
gates for example owned 45 of microsoft
when they went public in 1986 but since
then he's nearly sold all of it as he
only owns 1.3 of microsoft today now
bill is still worth 128 billion dollars
so i think it worked out all right but
if he had just held on to his initial
stake he'd be worth over a trillion
dollars similarly warren buffett was
famous for beating the s p 500 for
decades but today he's holding 150
billion worth of cash so clearly even
the richest people in the world have
gotten more conservative with time
one billionaire who never toned it down
though was bill huang
with time he placed riskier and riskier
bets which initially paid off growing
his fortune hundreds of fold but like
with all gamblers when you bet at all it
takes just one bad bet to wipe you out
and that's exactly what happened last
year when bill lost 20 billion dollars
in two days so here's the story of bill
huang and how he made and lost billions
in record time
taking a look back bill's story circles
back to south korea to the year 1964.
like many immigrant stories bill's
origins were rather grim
bill says that his parents struggled to
make ends meet and that he had to pick
up many part-time jobs to help them out
despite their bleak situation the family
never lost hope they were strong
christians and believed that one way or
another things would eventually work out
as bill reached his teenage years it
seemed like their wishes were coming
true as things were finally starting to
get better the family was able to
immigrate to las vegas and the bill's
father got a job as a pastor
unfortunately bill basically knew no
english which made it extremely
difficult for him to make friends excel
in school or get a job
but with persistence bill was able to
score a night shift at a mcdonald's and
the bill says that this is where he
learned to speak english just as things
were starting to pick up though bill's
father died this shattered the family's
morale and they would relocate to los
angeles despite the hardships bill knew
that with his father gone he was truly
on his own so he put his head down and
got to work bill eventually secured a
spot at ucla and majored in economics
and after his bachelor's bill turned
around and got an mba from carnegie
mellon university despite this strong
educational background bill struggled to
score a high-paying job out of college
and he ended up working as a low-level
salesman at hyundai securities
note that this was not hyundai motors so
bill was not a car salesman rather he
was a securities broker or basically a
stock salesman these guys aren't nearly
as common today due to the rise of
online brokerages that are intuitive and
simple to use but back in the day
securities brokers would call up a bunch
of people and try to convince them to
buy a particular stock or bond this job
did provide bill with a comfortable life
but given that he was still working here
when he was 33 years old it seemed like
bill would never achieve much more than
mediocrity career-wise that was until he
caught the eye of julian robertson
julian was the founder of the hedge fund
tiger management corporation by this
point tiger management was already
managing billions and they were one of
the fastest growing hedge funds in the
world but like bill julian had humble
roots and was initially a stock broker
himself julian felt that he could see
his younger self within bill so he
offered bill a golden ticket
julian offered to build a job as a
financial analyst at tiger management
and bill of course took the job bill
didn't just want to be another financial
analyst though he wanted to offer
something unique to the fund so he
proposed the idea of expanding tiger
management into asian investments while
bill had assimilated quite well into
american culture he never let go of his
asian culture bill felt that he had a
unique perspective on asian companies
and that he was the guy for asian
investments julian gave him a shot and
it quickly became clear that bill wasn't
bluffing he hit home run after home run
investing in dotcom favorites like sk
telecom amongst his peers bill became
known as the michael jordan of asian
investing with the help of bill tiger
management over doubled their assets
between 1997 and in 1998 from 10.5
billion dollars to 22 billion
this made tiger management the second
largest hedge fund in the world but it
wasn't all sunshines and rainbows to
achieve these mad returns bill was
investing in some of the most
speculative names of the dotcom bubble
many of his picks would crash 80 to 90
in the early 2000s and they haven't
moved since but fortunately for bill he
would never have to experience this
downfall as julian would shut down tiger
management you see tiger had made an
investment in u.s airways that wasn't
doing so well
aside from this julian was quite
satisfied he was in his 60s and was
already a multi-billionaire not to
mention he could sense that the stock
market was getting super overheated so
he decided that he didn't want to push
his luck in march of 2000 julian went
ahead and sold most of his stocks shut
down tiger management and distributed
all remaining profits to investors
considering that march 24 2000 was
literally the peak of the dotcom bubble
you could say that this was spectacular
timing or maybe julian selling was the
catalyst that turned the tide who knows
but either way shutting down tiger
management was a great call for julian
now we should note that julian ended up
back holding u.s airways to zero as the
company ended up going bankrupt
nonetheless by shutting down tiger in
2000 julian significantly reduced his
losses and made it out quite well it's a
shame that these kills didn't rub off on
bill anyway while julian was done with
running his own hedge fund he wasn't
completely done with the hedge fund
space quite yet he was well aware that
by shutting down tiger he put 97 bright
investors out of his job so julian
launched a seed funding program that
gave his former employees capital to
start their own hedge funds by the end
of the decade julian helped launch 38
different hedge funds which are often
referred to as tiger cubs and as you
would guess bill used this opportunity
to launch his own hedge fund called the
tiger asia
from the very beginning bill ran tiger
asia on the edge most of his positions
were outsized leveraged bets that could
go really well or really bad
for the first couple of years tigerasia
posted stellar numbers as the market
recovered from the dotcom crash by 2007
bill boasted a nutty 40 annualized
return managing a total of 8 billion
but when you're constantly playing with
fire it's only a matter of time until
you get burned and the bill's first burn
came in late 2008 during the height of
the great recession
considering the timing you would think
that bill got burned by an outsized
bullish bet which would actually be
quite understandable
but ironically bill actually got
destroyed by a short position
if you're not familiar with shorting it
it's basically the opposite of regular
stock investing
you make money when the stock goes down
and you lose money when the stock goes
up
anyway considering the recession thought
that it would be a great idea to short
volkswagen in theory he should have been
right but porsha's rapidly growing stake
in volkswagen set off an insane short
squeeze and if you thought the gamestop
short squeeze was not this was on
another level the percentage gains
weren't as much as gamestop as
volkswagen only grew 45 bags from 200 to
nearly 1 000 but given that volkswagen
wasn't initially a penny stock the short
squeeze actually made volkswagen the
biggest company in the world momentarily
this caused tiger asia to lose 23
percent of your entire portfolio and as
you would guess investors weren't happy
they were furious that bill was even
involved with volkswagen the hedge fund
was called tiger asia and it was
supposed to be focused on asian
investments many investors pulled their
money out of tigerasia after the fiasco
but bill did recover his colleagues say
that he learned from this mistake and
that ever since this experience he opted
to buy into heavily shorted stocks as
opposed to just sorting them as well
over the next couple of years bill
recovered from his mistake but
unfortunately his next mistake would be
unsalvageable in 2012 tiger asia would
get convicted of insider trading bill
was fined at 44 million dollars and he
was permanently banned from managing
other people's money with bella out of
the hedge fund scene you would think
that this was the end of bill's journey
but this was just the beginning of
archaegos
since bill could no longer manage
outside money he decided to manage his
own fund he had already made hundreds of
millions during his time in wall street
so he didn't need outside money if bill
just went ahead and invested his own
money it wouldn't have been that bad but
he wasn't happy with just making
ordinary returns bill wanted
extraordinary returns so he turned to
his favorite strategy leveraged trading
bill went ahead and borrowed money from
banks in order to fund his trading now
this itself is extremely dangerous but
the bill would take it to even the next
level you see banks aren't stupid enough
to loan bill hundreds of millions and
eventually billions to go gamble in the
stock market banks want to ensure that
there's very little risk of losing their
own capital so they use collateral and
margin calls for example let's say that
you wanted to buy 200 worth of apple
shares but you only have 100
chase will happily loan you the other
100
if you put up your 100 worth of apple
shares as collateral this way they have
quite a bit of leeway apple stock would
have to crash fifty percent for the
total position to be worth less than one
hundred dollars and the second that
apple does reach negative fifty percent
chase will sell all your stock and get
their money back on the other hand if
this stock skyrockets they're happy to
just collect interest and go on with
their day but what if you use the same
100 as collateral with many different
lenders
now as a retail investor banks will make
sure that you don't do this as they
don't really trust you but with someone
like bill they were much looser with
their restrictions which allowed bill to
take on 3-1 5-1 and even 8-1 leverage
bill used this strategy to 100x's
portfolio from 200 million dollars to 20
billion dollars and no one noticed a
thing you see as long as your positions
are playing out there's no problem with
the leverage it's only when your
positions go south that you get wiped
out by 2021 it bill's personal net worth
stood at 20 billion dollars but he was
trading with 100 billion dollars meaning
that he had 80 billion worth of debt
spread across multiple banks this means
that if bill's position dipped to just
20 percent he would have a negative net
worth and he should be margin called but
the banks didn't know this they thought
that they had 40 or 50 worth of leeway
and this became painfully evident when
one of bill's biggest positions crumbled
in march of 2021 vietcom cbs announced
that they would do a share offering
which cost the stock to tumble over 50
percent within a week given that this
was one of arkaigo's biggest positions
banks started a margin called bill and
this is when they realized that they
were screwed not only had bill blown
away his entire net worth but he had
also caused the banks including morgan
stanley goldman sachs credit suisse and
the nomura to incur 10 billion worth of
losses and with that archaicos filed for
bankruptcy
at the end of the day no one really
cared about the banks losing money as it
was due to their own lack of due
diligence but many were sad that bill
lost all his money you would see it
while bill was definitely a degenerate
gambler he was putting his winnings to
good use he wasn't blowing it on yachts
and jets instead he lived an extremely
modest life and donated a total of 590
million dollars to churches schools and
charities and the bill has repeatedly
iterated that his greatest love in life
is god and that the primary reason that
he was chasing money was so that he can
donate it so it's really quite a shame
that things have come to this
but he should have thought about that
before he gambled with 100 billion
dollars but that's just what i think do
you guys think bill has had a net
positive or net negative impact on the
world comment that down below
also drop a like if you respect bill's
balls of steel
and of course consider checking out our
international channels to watch our
videos in different languages and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one
you